Jimmy Kimmel is apologizing after
instances of him using the n-word and
doing blackface in past comedy bits have
resurfaced sometime at night
call below look up in sky and say what
the hell going on up there on his former
Comedy Central show the man show Kimmel
wore blackface makeup for impressions of
NBA star Karl Malone call Malone read
all TV about white people getting
deducted by alien additionally Fox News
recently unearthed a 1996 comedy
Christmas song from the Kevin and bean
radio show on K Rock FM in California in
the song titled Christmas time in the
LBC Kimmel imitates Snoop Dogg using the
n-word of multiple times in a statement
released on Tuesday Kimmel said he's
been reluctant to address the
controversy writing quote I knew doing
so would be celebrated as a victory by
those who equate apologies with weakness
and cheerful leaders who use prejudice
to divide us that delay was a mistake
there is nothing more important to me
than your respect and I apologize to
those who were genuinely hurt or
offended by the makeup I wore or the
words I spoke Kimmel says he never
considered his impressions of black
celebrities like Karl Malone to be
anything other than an imitation of a
fellow human being the late-night host
says looking back he finds these past
sketches embarrassing quote I believe
that I have evolved and matured over the
last twenty plus years and I hope that
is evident to anyone who watches my show
I know that this will not be the last I
hear of this and that it will be used
again to try to quiet me I love this
country too much to allow that I won't
be bullied into silence by those who
feign outrage to advance their
oppressive and genuinely racist agendas
Kimmel is currently on a summer vacation
that he says has been planned for more
than a year he plans to return to his
late-night talk show in September he
ended his statement with thank you for
giving me an opportunity to explain and
to those I've disappointed I am sorry
sincerely Jimmy Kimmel
[Applause]
you